- Wait, wait Malia, can we
do one last question please?
(women laugh)
Because there's a war going
on right now between
Millennials and Gen Z.
- Okay, we're getting into this.
- Let's get into it.
Let's get into it and solve it on daytime.
- [Malia] Okay let's do this.
- [Kelly] Solve it on daytime.
- [Man] How do you feel when
you look at Kelly and myself,
but, well let's make it
about me, you can dunk on me.
- [Malia] Okay, Sorry.
- Do you look at us and go, wow,
they are old, because I remember being 14,
- [Kelly] I just had this
conversation with someone,
cause I'm almost 40. And I was like,
I remember when I was young,
and I was like, 40 is so old.
- [Man] So old,
- [Malia] Guys!
- And then remember when we
could get our first credit card,
and they go, all you
have to do is pay it off
by 2018, and you go that year's not real.
(crowd laughs)
- Yeah know when you hear
it like, by the year 2032.
You're like, it's never going to be 2032.
That's not how time works.
- And the last two years,
we've maybe had that moment
when there's never going to be
- [Malia] Very, very true.
- Malia, your thoughts?
- My thoughts is, you know,
I don't think of you guys as not young,
I'm trying really hard to say the words
(crowd laughs)
- We are old.
- NO, no, no, oh my god! (Laughs)
- [Man] Malia, the star of
Netflix's "The Babysitter's Club"
- [Kelly] You are my favorite person
- [Man] says we are old.
- You are my favorite person.
- I promise, I don't.
I was talking to my hairstylist
this morning actually.
And they were like, no cap, Malia,
like really like get into
it. Are you, are we old?
And I was like, no, you guys are lit.
Like. You guys are really cool.
- We're supposed to be old,
to your 14 but I just
love, here's my thing.
You should have a job for
life. That was honest.